- What is
a typical profile of a
consultant at McKinsey?
This is a question that
I quite frequently get,
and most
answers I see and hear
about this questions
are based on experiences,
based on gut feelings.
But I recently came across
some pretty interesting data
on exactly this topic.
And in this video, I wanna
show you exactly this data.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich. I'm a
former McKinsey consultant.
And on my channel, I try to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So, let's jointly have a look at the data.
And even though the data is public,
I trust that most of you will
not have seen these numbers
in this way.
But before we jump into it,
let me quickly introduce you
to the sponsor of this video, DataCamp.
DataCamp is an online learning platform
where you can improve
your data analysis skills.
And you know that this is something
I talk about all the time.
This is really a crucial
part of your skillset.
If you want to succeed
in any consulting role,
and now trust in many roads in industry,
and for sure, in banking as well.
With DataCamp, there are
no previous data skills
needed to get started.
You can learn from things
as basic as X and 101,
to more advanced technical
things like for instance,
database manipulation SQL.
So for sure, if the things that I show
you here in this video are over your head,
you really have no idea
what this is all about.
There are some also very
introductory courses on Excel
in DataCamp, which I trust can help you.
They have over 300 courses
with interactive learning,
and you can also learn on
the go with the mobile app
that they have.
Personally, I very much
like the introduction
to SQL course, which already
helped me several times
on my own projects when I needed
to interact with databases.
So, give it a try and I trust
that working with DataCamp
indeed can fast track
your data analysis skills,
and these for sure, are so
crucial in any consulting role,
but also many other related roles as well.
So if this
piqued your interest and you
would like to try out DataCamp,
then invest in yourself.
Check out DataCamp via the
link in the video description,
and you will get access
to the first chapter
of every single course for free.
And now, without further ado,
let's dive into the data,
and what I want to show you here indeed,
is data on LinkedIn.
And you find what I will now show you
on the LinkedIn page of McKinsey,
and of course, this is an
analysis that you can do
for every other employer,
every other company
out there as well.
And specifically, where
you need to go is on
the LinkedIn page,
to the
(cursor clicks)
people tab to get access
to this type of statistic.
And as you can see here,
there are 34,000 employers
tracked at McKinsey here in the system.
And here, you do have access to some
pretty interesting statistics.
And I must say, I was quite impressed
what I was able to get out of this,
and also the type of analysis
that you can actually run
with this data.
So, what you see here
for the beginning is just
the basic understanding
of where the people live
that work at McKinsey.
And I think this alone is
quite insightful because here
you can see what the biggest
markets for such a company are.
And clearly, based on that,
here, you see the U.S.
is very large, and know
that here there are also
some additional areas which
clearly belong to the U.S.,
for instance, Greater Boston
area, Greater Chicago area.
Second is Germany then United Kingdom.
You're with London and then India.
And all the rest, a little
notable mention is Brazil,
and then also the UAE and France.
All the other countries
are quite small, right?
So, this clearly shows you
that the largest markets
are the U.S., are Germany, and are the UK.
And then, of course, with
countries like India,
you need to be aware that
several companies also
have support functions there.
So, this does not necessarily
mean that in terms
of consultance, these are
always the largest regions.
Though, of course, India is a region for
consulting services as well.
But what is the implication of this?
Well, if you are looking for
a job at a firm like McKinsey,
this clearly tells you that
the U.S., Germany, and the UK,
probably the most open positions to fill.
Of course, there will likely
also be more competition
for these positions
than in other countries,
especially for the U.S. and for the UK.
But what this also shows
us that probably, Germany,
while this certainly is
a large country with lots
of local applicants as well,
probably, Germany offers quite
a lot of great opportunities
for people applying because
apparently, this is a very,
very large market for the consulting firm.
And there are significantly
fewer people speaking German
than speaking English, and
would apply to the U.S.
or the UK.
And indeed, it is very
well-known that for instance,
the consulting positions
in the London office
are very, very competitive,
probably much more competitive
than the positions in many
of the other countries
just because so many
people want to work there.
Next are the universities.
What you see here is that these
private target universities
definitely do play an
important role of getting into
an MBB from like McKinsey, BCG, and Bain.
So if you go over this,
INSEAD is the graduate level
business school where I
also have my MBA from.
Harvard Business School, I
trust needs no introduction.
London School of Economics
and Political Science
is often also called LSE.
This is where I have my
master from, and then many
of these other schools you
will recognize yourself.
A notable mention here is
the Technical University of Munich.
This is a public university, so it's not
a private university, so you
can literally study here,
at least as a German with
no student fees at all.
And you can see that still,
universities like this,
are highly-ranked and very,
very competitive to get
into a firm like McKinsey.
Let's look into some more statistics.
And here, I'm especially
interested into what
these people study because
this indeed is also
a question that I very frequently get,
and this is what major
should you choose if you want
to apply to a firm like McKinsey.
And what you can clearly see
here is that business type
of majors such as business
administration, management,
economics, finance.
These are very competitive,
very relevant majors
if you want to apply to
a firm like McKinsey.
And indeed, and this
is true also, very much
from my experience.
Then the second most often are technical
MINT type of subjects.
Here, for instance,
mechanical engineering,
computer science, electrical engineering,
and hear this from my
subjective perception,
I would have believed that
this share of MINT type
of degrees is even higher
for the consultants at MBB.
Or, maybe I guess the numbers here just
prove me wrong.
Well, that being said,
you can also see the
political science and government.
Or, maybe also, here,
international global studies.
So, more liberal arts,
humanities types of programs
do have a sizable portion
of the people working
at McKinsey as well.
So, clearly can get in with these maybe
more niche profiles too,
even though these other ones
are probably the most
straightforward ones.
So, for those subject
programs who really have a
very specific profile,
do the right internships,
really tailor your profile
more towards consulting,
to then be able to make the cut.
So, while this already
might be insightful,
LinkedIn offers you even additional,
even more insightful (indistinct) options.
And what you can do indeed
is, now really drill down
and double click into
individual feeds like this.
So, let's imagine that you would
be interested to understand
what the best business
universities in your country are
to get into McKinsey.
And here for that, you would first need
to click your
(cursor clicks)
own business, now just to choose
the largest business category.
And now, you would click here
on Germany.
(cursor clicks)
And now, you would see here
because it's now filter,
for business and for
Germany, what the largest,
most successful
universities in Germany are
in terms of placement for
business study programs.
And here, you can see number one,
not surprisingly, the
University of Mannheim.
Second, WHU. This is a
private business university.
RWTH Aachen is, I must say,
quite surprising in my opinion.
For a business university,
this is very well-renowned
for technical subjects.
For my perspective, it
wasn't that renowned
for business subjects,
but I guess here again,
the data might prove
me just wrong as well.
Technical University of Munich.
So, you see all these names here.
Ludwig Maximilian University of Munich.
This is where I studied,
where I did my undergraduate degree.
So, I think this might
be quite interesting,
quite insightful if you are now selecting
your university as well, if
you want to get into McKinsey.
Though, also be aware that
maybe not everyone here
is working in a consulting role.
So, probably here, those
guys from this university,
those are rather profiles
that more likely will work
in back office role
than in consulting role.
But let me also show
second application on that.
So, let's imagine you are living
in France and would like to
know what the best
universities in France are
to get into McKinsey.
Then you just click on France,
now it's filtered by France.
And now, you see here indeed,
all the key feeders of the
French schools into McKinsey.
And here, it's the HEC Paris, it's INSEAD.
This school that frankly,
I've never heard of,
Essec Business School, ESCP,
Sciences Po, and so on.
So, I trust this gives
an overview as well.
(cursor clicks)
And similar to that,
you can also look into
India for instance.
(cursor clicks)
And here, you'll also see now
all the Indian universities
or rather, the universities
that feed into India
and McKinsey office.
And here, interestingly
enough, because this is also
a question that I frequently get is,
you do not need to study
abroad, for instance.
If you're living in India, to get into the
Indian McKinsey office, it
is very, very possible to
just study at a local
university because as
you can see here, all the top universities
are local Indian ones indeed.
So, I very much encourage
you to just play around
with this yourself, to get
exactly the insight out of it
that you want to have for
your profile, for your CV,
and potentially, for your career choices.
But now, I'd love to hear from you.
Do you already know
about this information source on LinkedIn?
Did you already look up
other employers like this?
Let me know what your favorite
functionalities of this are.
And that's all.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please just
throw the like button
(circle ticks)
for the YouTube algorithm.
(circle bubbles)
And of course, also subscribe
to this channel to stay up
to date on all my content.
I'm also active on other platforms,
such as Instagram, Twitch, or TikTok.
You can find me under
my handle, firmlearning.
I also want to thank the
sponsor of this video, DataCamp.
Check the link in the video
description to DataCamp
to get access to the first
chapter of every course
for free.
And a big
thanks of course, also to
the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a difference.
Thank you
so much for that.
My name is Heinrich, I release new videos
every single Saturday,
so see you soon again next week.
Until then, bye-bye.